>> That's a good story David. Now let's consider a different set of issues.
Imagine that I told you a story. Bob went to a restaurant and sat down. But
nobody came to serve him for quite awhile. Eventually, when someone did appear,
he ordered a hamburger. The hamburger took a long time before it came.
And when it did come, it was burned. Bob was not very happy.
He didn't even finish the hamburger. Do you think Bob left a large tip?
Well, I expect most of you would say no. He did not leave a large tip.
If we had to wait for a long time. And if the food that came eve,
eventually, was not of very high quality. You'd probably not even ask tip. But
how did you come to that answer? Why did you expect,
that in this particular case, Bob will not leave a large tip? Again,
this connects to your notion of a story. It connects to your notion of a story,
of what happens in a restaurant. Why do people leave tips? When do they
leave them? To put it another way, stories help you make sense of the world.
They help you [INAUDIBLE] expectations, even before [UNKNOWN]. They allow
us to make connections between evens that otherwise might appear disparate. So
in this lesson, we'll look at another structured knowledge representation called
scripts. For representing stories or the kind that we are talking about.
And we will see how this knowledge for presentation allows us to make sense of
the world. And answer the kinds of questions that we are talking about.